this is some video we're going to show
you from townhall.com joe biden
was giving a speech and if you ever ever
want to know what the soft bigotry of
low expectations is
well listen to old joe the data shows
young black entrepreneurs are just as
capable of succeeding given the chance
as white entrepreneurs are
but they don't have lawyers they don't
have they
they don't have accountants but they
have great ideas
does anyone doubt this whole nation be
better off
from the investments those people make
and i promise you that's why i set up
this
national small business administration
that's much broader
because they're going to get those loans
amela i'm uh reviewing my paperwork here
you are black
is that correct i am indeed that is very
true
i want to stay for the record i don't
see color dave thank you go ahead
steve you are definitely not black i
mean i can't see
do you have a lawyer or an accountant
and if not do you need help finding one
because we live
really kind of close i hear you my guys
i do not currently have a lawyer or an
accountant but if i needed one i'm sure
that i could use my faculties to to get
one for myself
seriously though when you hear a
statement like that like what does that
make you feel make you think like like
that
is racism man that is racism
it is on its very face it's racism and
it's a big part of what made me leave
the left like you said the soft bigotry
of low expectations so now we can add to
the list that black people can't get
lawyers
they can't get accountants they can't
get voter id they can't get into college
without help from anybody they need
their businesses elevated on platforms
like youtube and netflix and ubereats
it's just they expect so little of us
because we are the victims of american
society
apparently jack i mean obviously
you're not a biden supporter but are you
shocked at how quickly
this thing has just completely derailed
or at least become
everything that a bunch of us warned it
was going to become
you know so i'm actually a little bit
more in the process
of i would say i'm in the camp of i want
to step on the gas pedal right
i want biden to go as much i want as
much joe biden as possible i want him
giving speeches 24 7. i want him doing
live streams you should bring him on
reuben report right
i want him out there all the time
so you just want to exacerbate this is
the point it'll just be obvious to
everyone that's the idea
like yeah the more abiding give us the
less they'll be able to cover it up the
more stories you'll get like this the
more comments you'll get like this where
you know and of course if you if you
push the left on these uh these
statements they'll say well he's clearly
referencing systemic racism and the
the injustices that were done against
certain communities of color in this
country
that have created disparities yeah i can
do it right that can
create a disparities in access to uh it
needed american
economic and legal institutions and he's
really just a paragon of virtue and it's
like no cut the crap right
we everybody knows kamala harris is
waiting
in the wings she's either going to wait
for that resignation or she is going to
trigger the 25th amendment because she
wants to be in that chair steve let's
not forget
she was polling at quite literally zero
percent when she stepped out of the
democratic primary but
here we are well her one claim to fame
as a presidential candidate
was successfully calling joe biden a
racist
uh in one of their debates what what i
think we're watching
with this administration is take
take the obama the obama years and let's
fast forward to
the the current trend of cultural
devolution we're at now compared to
where we were in
2009 2012 etc so accelerated a few more
years but then removed the stagecraft
aspect of the obama presidency that they
were so
effective going back to his nomination
speech his first run where he
had like the greek columns and he gave
the speech there in uh
in la i think it was they understood the
stagecraft they were the first
campaign to jump on social media i mean
when you got a message from
uh from michelle obama we didn't know
what micro targeting and stuff was you
thought she was really calling you and
left you a voicemail right
they understood the stagecraft and that
that covered a lot of the cloud pivot
sins of his eight years in the white
house
well that's all gone now and now you're
getting all the policy but not of the
none of the pomp
and so you remove all of that stagecraft
you remove the power
of obama's persona his ability to relate
to people communicate to people
all of that is gone now and is replaced
by a construct meaning you get the
policies
but then a guy who as a vehicle is just
riddled with dementia
and i think that's why you're seeing
this thing unravel fast is
is now you don't have to go through
layers of obama's personality in order
to get to the root of an
issue the issues are stripped bare right
away because biden is just not an
effective symbol
yeah i'ma let you know i don't want to
do the identity politics thing but
at some level i mean are you seeing
friends family etc that are just like
like is anyone breaking basically like
have you seen anyone that wasn't really
sure
before the election now be like four
months in and going
boy black people can't get a computer
they can't vote you know they can't get
an id
like all the stuff that we've talked
about here are you seeing some people
that are finally like ah
maybe maybe there's something wrong here
i think it's slowly placing a little
in the armor but we all know the
left and the left does not want to admit
that they're wrong or that they've done
something that has had ramifications
that are poor on society so
it's very hard to truly break through
that barrier of left
of leftism of this massive support for
joe biden but i think
like jack said we just need to put him
on tv more he needs to be live streaming
he needs to be on twitter he needs to be
making youtube videos
because that is going to expose him he
is doing all the work himself
i'm this this one's for all of you guys
jack i'll start with you first but are
you guys shocked that's
the way the mainstream media still runs
cover for him
that despite the fact that we can all
see this stuff on twitter and on youtube
and all of these shows get more views
than cnn we all know that not that
that's that many views
because nobody's watching cnn but that
the mainstream still just they will not
discuss these things when he doesn't
know what he's talking about or when
he's blatantly racist
or when he's bumbling around the stage
or whatever it might be that they still
just don't do it
jack what do you think no i i think it's
different because i think that joe biden
he's just a ratings crusher for them
uh they are all still focused on trump
because the dirty little secret is
he's the only thing keeping any of these
outlets afloat right it's it's all just
anti-trump trump hate uh mueller's gonna
get trump okay maybe mueller's not gonna
get him but
adam schiff's gonna get him right they
will talk about trump
all day long they want to goad him into
running again
they need him to run again if any of
their financial business plans are going
to be able to continue out forward
right that's why they don't talk about
biden because at the end of the day
he's just boring and even people on
their own side don't care about him
steve but just yesterday uh we were told
that trump's telling people he's going
to be reinstated in august that's what
they said on cnn it must be true
i want to go back to what you just said
about twitter this is where
there is a use for twitter is that
cognitive dissonance
is is can cannot be ignored any longer
because
when we used to have just you know rival
media streams
you could say i was on the air i'm in my
own you know habitat i'm not observing
your ecosystem i don't know what you
guys talk about but i would say
to anybody that's currently any of the
four of us on this panel go right after
we're done here
tweet something incendiary on a few
verboten topics
and i can promise you um that i mean i
i've seen this happen
a bunch of cnn producers or new york
times or washington post reporters
who don't know if my last name is
pronounced dies or dace suddenly
they're on the phone calling me and
asking for clarification
uh did you really mean this i mean what
do you think this means right and so the
idea
if they're pouncing on us like i'll give
you an example dave
so i used to do a lot of panels on cnn
msnbc just because it was fun
and then the trump era came and they
didn't want to have people like me on
anymore because they just wanted to
further a narrative rather than a
conversation
until trump met with the guy over the
killer over there in north korea and i'm
just not big on
uh palin around with the folks over
there in pyongyang
sure enough after three years of
ignoring me
cnn called me right away to see if i
wanted to come on the network that day
because i didn't like trump's uh entrees
with the north koreans that's an
example of what we're talking about here
and so if they know when we say
something that fits their narrative
or they find incendiary that they can
use against us that means they're aware
of all the other times we're pointing
out
when they're completely full of feces at
the exact same time
and yet they just choose to ignore that
what does that tell you right well
you got to be feeling pretty good about
it though because you're getting in the
content creation game and everyone's
ignoring that nonsense at this point
i know i'm not catching too much heat
right now but i
i we all know revolutionaries they need
a villain and they will move on to
somebody after they move on from trump
there will always be something to fight
against and that's why these media
outlets need
some sort of villain somebody to put in
the hot seat somebody who's evil